today the senate of the united states
led by chuck schumer
should have been led by mitch mcconnell
but now it's led by chuck schumer is
going to start the consideration
on the conviction of president trump for
the impeachment charge
that was brought against him by the
house of representatives remember that
single impeachment charge essentially
suggested that trump was responsible for
inciting a riot at the capitol building
on
january 6th that was the main part of
the impeachment charge there were other
ancillary parts like his
earlier call with georgia's secretary of
state brad raffensberger but the main
part of the charge is that he was
personally responsible
for the incitement of the violence that
happened on january 6th now the big
problem
with that charge is really that he
is not by any legal definition
responsible for incitement and it's very
difficult to make the claim that he is
responsible for incitement because of
the colorful language that he used
in the months leading up to january 6th
but that
other politicians who use similarly
colorful language are not also guilty of
incitement when violent breaks out
from people who agree with them this is
the biggest flaw in the entire
democratic argument with regard to
impeachment
now there are some republicans who voted
for impeachment in the house there are
cases that trump had abused his power
that he'd been lying about the results
of the election that he'd been telling
lies about voter irregularity and voter
fraud and whipping people
into a frenzy and that it was sort of a
foreseeable effect of that that
something bad would happen
but again the wording of the incitement
charge is pretty specific
and beyond that there is no neutral
standard that applies across the board
when it comes to an impeachable offense
on the basis of this fact pattern
and that is the case that trump's
defense is making so we're gonna get to
what trump's defense looks like because
that's gonna start rolling out today
the trial actually begins with a
four-hour debate today on the
constitutionality
of bringing an impeachment charge
against a person who's no longer in
office remember he is former president
trump he's not actually president trump
and frankly if he wanted what was best
for the country
i think there's a solid case to be made
that the country is better off just
kind of moving on and the reason i say
that is not because trump shouldn't bear
the political consequences of of what he
wrought over the couple of months after
the election
i think he is going to bear those
political consequences in whatever way
the american public
sees fits to bring those consequences i
mean the number one consequence of his
behavior over the past four years is
that he's no longer president of the
united states
the simple fact of the matter is if he
had been as silent on social media
during his presidency as he has been
since he was banned from social media in
the aftermath of january 6 he would
probably still be president
so it's not as though consequences have
not attended to trump's behavior
and the people who actually engaged in
violence those people will be tracked
down those people will be brought to
trial those people will spend time in
jail
as well they should and if democrats are
ever willing to bring forth evidence of
their most outrageous allegations
which is that there are members of
congress who are complicit in the attack
well then members of congress will end
up
in jail but when it comes to the
question of whether it is good for the
country as a broad matter
for us to be relitigating trump's
presidency after he lost an election
in november or whether we ought to be
focused on you know the crises at hand
namely covet
the economy and all the rest i think
that increasingly if
there's a reason both democrats and
republicans want to move fast on this
thing republicans want to move fast on
it because they think that it's
basically just political gamesmanship
which is correct
and democrats want to move fast on this
thing because i think they recognize
that if this drags out for weeks and
weeks
americans are just gonna get tired of it
because this is what happens with
virtually every impeachment trial at the
very beginning
of the impeachment trial over ukraine
americans were largely supportive
of impeaching trump by polling data and
then as the thing continued
americans were like what are we doing
again why are we doing this again
what seriously and you're going to get
that even more now because at least at
that point trump was president
now trump's just some guy golfing in
mar-a-lago so the the idea for most
americans that we should be
expending enormous quantities of time
and not only time by the way cash
you know we're going to spend 500
million taxpayer dollars 500 million
taxpayer dollars
to have troops all over washington dc
during this senate impeachment
trial you know that now honestly i would
love to hear members of the law
enforcement community explain
just why we need a completely
militarized dc right now
because there's been no violence since
january 6th it's not to say there
couldn't be
that's not to say that maybe they don't
have evidence that we haven't seen
but governor desantis in florida
governor abbott in texas they already
brought home their national guard
contingent they're like um we're not
seeing
a ton of fomenting violence we're not
seeing giant rallies outside the senate
today so why exactly are we spending 500
million
taxpayer dollars to keep washington dc
in a state of military lockdown
i mean just on the face of it it's kind
of bizarre so here's how the trial is
going to roll out today according to the
hill senate leadership announced on
monday
they've reached a deal on the framework
for former president trump's impeachment
trial
it'll start today for the information of
the senate the republican leader and i
in consultation with both the house
managers and former president trump's
lawyers have agreed to a bipartisan
resolution to govern the structure and
timing of the impending trial said
senate majority leader
chuck schumer apparently they confirmed
on the right side of the aisle that this
was happening
the timeline would allow the trial to
wrap up as early as next week if both
sides agree
not to call witnesses and this is the
big question right now is whether the
sides are going to call witnesses
under the current deal the senate is
going to debate and vote today on
whether the trial is constitutional
the effort to declare the trial and
constitution will fall short rand paul
foster
forced to vote on this issue late last
month 44 republican senators supported
that particular effort
there were very few republicans who
sided with the idea that it was
constitutional now that was an easy
procedural way out there are some
republicans who are making the case it's
not constitutional to push forward with
this tom cotton from arkansas is one of
those here's senator cotton explaining
the constitutional case against
convicting a president of an impeachable
offense after he has already left office
i think it's beyond the senate's
constitutional authority to have an
impeachment proceeding
the point of which is to convict and
remove from office a man who left office
three weeks ago
i think it's also a set of misplaced
priorities the democrats continue to
obsess about donald trump
when donald trump left office and went
to florida three weeks ago when the
senate should be focused on things like
how to expand vaccine production and
distribute it more quickly
those are the priorities the american
people want us to focus on not an
inquest into
who is now a private citizen it's an
interesting constitutional debate on the
right side of the aisle basically
the republicans who say that it's
unconstitutional to push forward with
this that's people like tom cotton
or rand paul their case is that it is an
impeachment trial the purpose of an
impeachment trial is to remove from
office a person
who apparently is now already out of
office so what exactly is the point
and on the other side of the aisle there
are people who say yes he was impeached
in the house
but the conviction is still part of the
process that happens in the senate
and one of the possibilities is barring
somebody from running for office in the
future
on the basis of a senate conviction so
here's pat toomey who's a republican
senator from pennsylvania making the
opposite case
you did have um you know 45
republican senators vote to suggest that
they didn't think it was appropriate to
conduct a trial so
you can infer how likely it is that
those folks will vote to convict
i disagreed with their assessment i
think it is constitutional i think it's
clearly constitutional
to conduct a senate trial with respect
to an impeachment
in this case the impeachment occurred
prior to the president's leaving office
okay so how is this actually going to
roll out the way that this is actually
going to roll out
is the opening arguments then start on
wednesday so under the current deal
the house impeachment managers and
trump's team will have 16 hours over two
days each to present their case
to the senate which is actually a faster
pace than the first trump trial both
sides got 24 hours in that trump trial
at that point chuck schumer was like
we're rushing this thing even now
because mitch mcconnell was in charge
now chuck schumer wants to rush this
thing so much
that both sides get 16 hours to present
their case
and you can bet money that if the
democrats start calling witnesses like
if they start calling up aoc to testify
to how terrified she was in the building
that was
you know 0.3 miles away from the capitol
building protected by police and was
never under assault from riders
if they want to call people like aoc
then you can certainly bet republicans
will then call aoc to rebut aoc
and ask her about her own violent
language with regard to republicans and
riots and all of the rest
the way this is going to work is if one
side opens that can of worms with regard
to impeachment witnesses you can bet the
other side certainly will
as well the deal does leave open the
door to calling witnesses
the house impeachment managers
previously invited trump to testify
under oath his attorneys rejected that
because if you are trump's attorney the
last thing you ever want is donald trump
in a legal proceeding saying anything it
is the worst job in the world being
donald trump's attorney
you can tell because of the churn i mean
seriously that is a bad job because the
first rule of lawyering
is that you get your client to shut up
and then you are the one who is the
mouthpiece for your client
but that is not donald trump's forte is
shutting up
and so being donald trump's lawyer is
always difficult although there are
reports out today
that donald trump shockingly has finally
learned that actually
his best pr tactic may be to not say
things
apparently he's like off on the golf
courses and people around him are
telling him you know people are still
paying attention to you
and you using your social media
sparingly as opposed to
using it like you know just word vomit
like that that's actually
an effective tactic and trump seems to
have learned that which is why he's
making so few public statements
would to god that he had learned that in
the first year of his presidency
both sides are gonna end up with two
hours four closing arguments
chuck schumer says in previous trials
there will be equal time for senator
questions and for closing arguments
and an opportunity for the senate to
hold deliberations if it so chooses and
then we're going to vote
on the articles of impeachment so that
is the procedure as it is going to play
out
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content